scientists say climate change is getting
worse and there could be serious
consequences for our planet in the next
20 years surface temperature the planet
is warmer than it was a hundred years
ago is this whole global warming problem
going to be a lot easier to solve than
anybody imagined what the world needs
now is nuclear energy hi welcome to
another cold fusion video in previous
videos we've gone over many future
energy solutions all with their pros and
cons but today we'll be looking at
something a little bit different a
strange as it may sound
nuclear energy may be the future and
thorium may be the fuel that
revolutionized us that future it could
just be what we need to make a safe
minimal waste and carbon neutral energy
supply recently if there's been a lot of
excitement around thorium so let's take
a look at why thorium is a better fuel
its downsides and how the Cold War
hindered a safer nuclear future with
thorium
[Music]
every time you turn on your laptop click
on your house lights or even charge your
new electric car you are using
electricity mostly created from burning
fossil fuels over 80% of the global
energy supply is created using
greenhouse gas emitted coal oil and
natural gas renewables such as hydro
solar and wind face some economic and
practical hurdles
although these sources are improving it
may be a while before the full global
energy supply is fueled by renewables in
the mean time it's clear that we need
something better than what we have today
and this is where nuclear energy comes
in when the word nuclear is mentioned
Hiroshima Chernobyl and Fukushima often
springs to mind or maybe you remember
the dangerous radioactive green sludge
from The Simpsons the Homer worked with
nuclear energy is clean but dangerous
but with the use of thorium maybe
nuclear can drop the dangerous tag and
just be clean let's take a look at how
thorium could revolutionize the world
there are many positives to thorium
especially when compared with uranium
let's take a look at some thorium is
named after the god of thunder for its
it's two doors down from uranium on the
periodic table and is much like it's
concentrated stable cousin uranium is
commonly used for nuclear power plants
but there are many advantages when
thorium is used instead for one thorium
is a much more highly concentrated or
thin uranium meaning it takes less work
to extract the same amount of energy
generating potential during the mining
process there is also three times more
thorium in the Earth's crust than
uranium in terms of energy production
one tonne of thorium is approximately
equal to 35 tonnes of uranium and 4
million tons of coal this is largely due
to the improved efficiency and recycling
properties of a thorium reactor through
Neutron bombardment thorium is turned
into uranium 233 which is then used for
nuclear reactions
unlike uranium-235 which is used in most
nuclear power generation the thorium
derived to uranium 233 is terrible as a
nuclear weapon actually that's one of
the reasons why thorium reactors were
not further funded in the 1960s while
the US government was in the midst of
the Cold War there was ongoing
search projects into both uranium and
thorium as suitable nuclear fuels the
u.s. decided to opt for uranium power
plants partly because the byproducts can
be used for nuclear weapons they fear
that the Soviets were doing the same in
these strange circumstances uranium came
out on top and over the next few decades
uranium became the industry standard and
a major reason why any new power plants
for uranium and not thorium reactors
thorium is a weak radioactive metal
while uranium in its enriched form is
difficult to contain uranium mining for
yellowcake is also very dangerous to
workers as the or releases radon gas
when mind due to the nature of thorium
power generating processes being in
liquid form is both the fuel and the
coolant in the reactor this means that
it can self regulate the temperature
slowing down the process if the
temperature gets too high supposedly
this makes thorium reactors incapable of
having a meltdown and that's pretty
interesting and probably the thing that
sets thorium reactors apart from their
contemporary counterparts while nuclear
power plants may be considered clean as
they don't emit greenhouse gasses they
still do produce nuclear waste currently
this waste degrades over a half-life of
100,000 years for thorium this is 300
years and in addition it's much less
toxic in comparison according to some
estimates thorium may also produce 0.6%
of the radioactive waste when compared
to uranium based nuclear power so for
all of these positives there still are
some negatives to thorium due to the
focus on uranium thorium reactor designs
have been neglected currently thorium
reactors are still in the research stage
in many countries after a need interest
but while this is good this still means
that we are a while away from any
projects being functional
due to the lack of infrastructure the
startup cost for this technology are
very high figures for capital and
operational expenditure at this stage is
all speculative and no one really knows
the associated costs that this will be
in practice
hence the race between uranium and
thorium may already be over as the
start-up costs may cancel out any of the
long term benefits of what might be a
better safer fuel thorium isn't perfect
it's still radioactive and still
produces waste this may pose another
issue when it comes to handling and
shielding the material perhaps the
biggest threat to thorium nuclear energy
is the fact that there hasn't been much
experience with it in an industry where
the stakes are higher both financially
and in terms of safety the philosophy is
quite conservative it's unlikely that
people will take risks and experiment
with thorium hence the progress of this
technology is bound to be slow during
research stages it's often easy to
protect the benefits it's only during
testing that the real issues and hurdles
become apparent while we are certainly
interested in looking continuing to look
at thorium as a possibility and
particularly a possibility for for the
future the fact remains that we have an
entire fuel cycle built up around
uranium and it would be a dramatic shift
and very costly shift to move on any
sort of short time scale to forea
[Music]
thorium's got potential a lot of it
thorium reactors are in a good position
to take over their carbon neutral and
compared to current nuclear processes
results in much less waste they're also
safer has a more abundant fuel source as
a raw material and their potential to be
used as nuclear weapons is minimal solar
wind hydro and other processes could be
ideal for the environment but we live in
a world which demands electricity and
that demand at least at the moment can't
be met purely by renewables just yet it
is very possible that renewables will
get to that stage but in the meantime
there's no harm in taking a deeper look
at thorium you could feed our energy
demand while decreasing the amount of
greenhouse gases being emitted into our
atmosphere it's an interesting and
exciting technology and it just may be
the technology that we need ok so that
wraps up our look at thorium reactors if
you did enjoy this video and want to see
more videos on science and technology
feel free to subscribe this has been -
go go you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll catch you soon again for the
next video cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion are you thinking
[Music]